i want to give you an idea about what
we're going to be doing
over the course of the semester with the
specific readings that i've chosen for
this
this class focused on love
friendship and desire we are going to be
studying philosophy in general
but we're going to be taking this this
particular theme
and so metaphysics will fit in with here
ethics will fit in with here
philosophy of action epistemology
all these concerns get sort of sucked
into these these things
and these are really interesting to
think about
uh in part because all of you have
experience with this
it's not like say metaphysics
all on its own you know maybe some of
you have not speculated about what is
everything made of
before but all of you have
had friendships and all of you have felt
love
and maybe fallen in love and
had relationships all of you had and
still have
all sorts of desires and you've
witnessed other people
having desires and how those play
themselves out these are things that we
make movies about we write songs about
and we write literature of that these
are things where
the the most sublime things occur in
human nature
and also some of the most uh demonic
things things occur and also some of the
most uh pathetic
and silly and
you know good fodder for comedy shows
and then things that we
we want to strive for and aim at so
i think you'll find this very rewarding
to look at what philosophers have had to
say about this
now think about those those big
questions
just for a moment while i put some other
things on the board
those big questions about love or
friendship that i had you
sort of maul over for your own account
what i want to do
while you're doing that is put up some
greek words that people often want to
use to divide up
love and you may have encountered these
before
this look familiar to any of you
euros agape philia
i think if you've encountered this
before it was probably in a
religion class some sort of catechism
or perhaps a psychology class
but these usually get talked about in
religious frameworks in part because
it's become quite popular
since the 20th century to use the euros
agape philia
distinction to talk about um what
christian love want to be like you know
it should be like agape and not this
gyro stuff that messy
sexual you know romantic stuff
really disinterest the love in the other
person um
you know that that's what it's all about
and then you know philia
was based on having things in common
and you don't have to have something in
common with someone who you love
love is a activity a choice not an
emotion
that's usually where this comes from
then storge comes in
as a fourth kind one of the
classic books on this from the 20th
century is this the four loves by c.s
lewis
where he goes he uses this
classification but it's not quite so
crude as that
another guy anders negren is responsible
for the eros agape thing he wrote a
whole book about it and it's been very
influential
on religious people as a matter of fact
even even
pope benedict's encyclical
god is love use this three-part
classification
here these greek words so why are people
so so fascinated with these
three greek words and then this leftover
store game well because they they came
to represent
some fundamental ways in which a human
being could be oriented towards
another human being or something else
and
eros when we say euros what
immediately comes to mind i mean if
you're classically trained it might be
the little cupid guy at valentine's day
you know
that's euros but what do you really
think of that
erotic right that's the word that comes
from it what does erotic mean
has to do does that have to do with love
lost yeah lost and and lust for
fear no sex
yeah sexuality um and and sexuality
is and sexual desire is one of the
um strongest forms of euros
one of the most fundamental kind the
greeks the way that they use this term
you could feel
eros towards a lot of other things they
they would actually say
the the drunk actually does have euros
for beer
desire for beer so this you can think of
as as desire
and when we feel desire um
in general do we feel desire for things
that we already have
or do we feel desire for what we don't
have
isn't this part of the problem too with
romantic relationships you know
the person looks so attractive i got to
spend all my time with them
and then you're with them and you're
like yeah they're boring me i've got
you know i've experienced that i want to
move on whether this other one over here
is very interesting
well that's euros that's the way a lot
of people conceive of it
and the ancient greeks tended to see it
that way they didn't call
everything that fit under that euros
and they didn't use this word
eros or its verbal cognates only for
that sort of desirous
need launch is what lewis calls it um
but that is a very important part of our
human nature right
i mean take love out of the picture
let's just think about desire why are
you here in this classroom
at 10 30 in the morning
did you really really really want to
study philosophy for its own sake
anybody i didn't even when i was taking
intro philosophy
myself the whole story of how i became a
philosophy majors was
pretty comic um
so why are you here you have other
desires right
education yeah get an education and and
that's
is it only for its own sake or do you
want to do something with
that
yeah to succeed get a job and
your job is that going to be the whole
focus of your life is
you have eros for the job just give me
more and more work
or is there something else you want out
of life yeah you need the job to succeed
to
spend time doing other things that you
desire to do yeah you have some desires
that are higher and some desires that
are lower
some that you you know are the real goal
like if you could
here here would be a question to ask
yourself
if you won the lottery tomorrow and it
wasn't just like the little lottery but
you know
millions right even after the government
takes it's 50
cut the state of new york probably takes
a big bite too i'm willing to bet too
would you stay in school and
would you go and find a job
no i think a lot of people would say
that yeah
um i mean if you were you might actually
like go back to school eventually and
say
yeah i kind of enjoyed taking classes
but you you wouldn't just take whatever
your advisor told you'd take what you
wanted to take wouldn't you
i'm interested in this i don't care if i
need this to graduate i may never
graduate i'm i'm loaded i don't need to
graduate right
same thing with jobs some of you might
work
i'd probably keep doing a lot of what
i'm doing even if i made it made it rich
because i love what i do it's very
satisfying
but i'll tell you i worked a lot of jobs
where that was not the case
and i think a lot of you will have jobs
that at least at the beginning
hopefully only at the beginning will be
like that and then eventually you'll
find satisfaction
it and euros can be part of that
desire love in that sense
let me shift way over here now to storge
storge is a is a term that in general in
greek signifies
affection and it's usually used for the
kind of affection that
parents feel towards their children
children feel towards
their parents towards siblings familial
affection
um but you know you can think of other
types of affection that are kind of
similar you know like with your pets
you might have storge with your pets
your pets depending on what kind of pets
they are may feel it towards you
dogs cats very clearly ferrets
cows you know if you're a 4-h person
they they do too horses tarantulas
probably not you know uh fish probably
not
um reptiles it's kind of out the verdict
on that
they they don't seem to have enough of
the the million brain structure that's
needed to feel this kind of thing that's
what
a lot of people think but i don't know
maybe maybe they do
we probably shouldn't you know make
definitive declarations about this
unless we know for sure
that's a good epistemological point
right but this is something that's
different
than just you know romantic desire
or need or want or something like that
how can you tell well at least for some
people
don't they stick around and keep showing
up after they no longer need their
parents
i mean this is one way to tell whether
you were a good parent or not
right or if you know your kids turned
out to be good kids
they actually want to spend time with
you even when they're not getting money
from him
when they don't need something from you
you know that's there's something there
that is that is something worth thinking
about
philia this is what is often translated
as friendship
the greeks used it sometimes in wider
terms like you could be
filohippo so you know a lover of horses
you know people are really into horses
i guess feel a musica you know would be
somebody who's really into music
philosophia means literally love of
wisdom
but sort of friendship love with wisdom
trying to become more and more like that
that wisdom that you want to partake in
and you know friendship is somewhat
different than
say romantic love erotic love or
just pure need and getting that need
satisfied desire
isn't it at least some friendships i
mean there may be some friends who we we
just use
maybe they're not friends in the full
sense that's that's something we want to
explore later
uh and then finally there's this word
agape
are any of you familiar with agape love
has even heard that talk to you about it
means like love without sex right
or like without desire yeah it could um
i mean you could actually you could have
like a say a marriage where you had all
these components
um as opposed to what they used to call
mariage blanche a white marriage
literally where they live together as
brother and sister but but no sex
um sounds like a terrible kind of kind
of arrangement to me but
uh yeah it's it's it's
it's not so much that it it takes sex
out of the picture
it's supposed to be disinterested it's
not trying to get something
from the object that's loved it's for
the sake of the
object itself so if i treat you well
even though i'm not going to get
anything out of it and i don't have
anything in common with you and we're
not like you know
siblings or cousins or anything like
that that could be agape love
this is often held up as you know the
ideal for for
uh various religions you know if you
think about the story of the good
samaritan
the guys who's the guy who got beaten up
by robbers
on the roadside they really kick the
tar out of him and everybody else passes
by him
the only reason why they pass by in the
story you know the
ritual issues and this guy's
not even of the same race this year and
race
meant something very different back then
but you got to remember in the story of
the good samaritan samaritans and jews
hated each other just hated each other
there's all sorts of bad blood reasons
for that
but this guy says well he's a human
being
so i'm going to get him out of the
gutter and take him to the end
and tell the innkeeper you know wash him
up and i'm going to dress his wounds
here's some money i'll be back in town a
little bit later
if you need more money to take care of
them all i'll front you that money too
now what's he getting out of that
getting to feel like the big shot the
important guy
that's not his motivation and he you
know it's not only that he doesn't have
anything in common with this guy
they're from you know rival
organizations
he should hate this guy he should feel
the opposite of friendship for him
but he doesn't instead he treats him
well
that's that's often held up as you know
like one of the the paragon
uh examples of of um agape
that's why that story got told at that
point right um
so these are all different
classifications now
ask yourself this and this is a
philosophical question does this cover
the whole gamut
is this an adequate classification
that's part of what we're going to
explore over the course of the semester
now let's think about some of the
questions that you guys have and and all
you know if we run out i've got a few of
my own that we will definitely look at
over the course of the semester
what are some things that have always
puzzled you about love or friendship
i'm sure that some things have puzzled
you because these aren't murky
mysterious
human topics that tie in with who we are
yeah why
we always get to that one where we
desire what we can't have
oh that's a good one yeah the desire
for the unattainable itself why is the
forbidden fruit always more
tempting there there's actually an
italian proverb and i don't know how to
say in italian but it goes
if only water if only drinking water
were sinful it would taste so much more
sweet
the idea being that if somebody lays
down a prohibition
that somehow it makes it feel you know
like we get a bigger charge out of it
when we
cross that line yeah that's a good one
we will explore that that question
through some of these
what else what else have
weighed on your mind kept you awake at
night
besides like is this person in love with
me or not
should i should i pursue this person
more general things
i know you guys have something seems shy
at this point this semester
yeah how do you go from being friends
one day to like not friends
yeah that's a good one
it's not enough to know the definition
of friendship or how we get to be
friends
how do you remain friends and and you
know are there like
certain critical moments where it could
go this way or go this way
there's another related question too
about like when you go from being
friends
to being romantically involved does that
like destroy the friendship
does it have to destroy the friendship
yeah
um like
why can we affect uh people in harmful
ways
oh yeah very important question is love
always good for us
you know we we hear love talked about is
a great good
and in general it is um but but can't be
harmful for us and maybe we have to
distinguish between different kinds of
love in order to do that you know like
you know think about agape club
could you give so much that you actually
do harm to yourself or to your
people who you ought to be feeling these
other forms with
you leave them out as a result that that
could be bad love
how do we draw these lines those are
important questions
what happens when people fall in love or
form friendships what is actually going
on there in in
the psyche of those people is it all
above board
or is there you know really strange
subterranean things going on
that maybe we can't actually generalize
about
maybe with some things we say well
philosophy can't actually deal with it
that's purely
personal purely individual that's a
question for philosophy
um are these just feelings
or do they reflect something deeper in
our human nature
do they always blind us
do they turn thinking off or reason off
or could they sometimes be ways to
actually see the truth of things more
clearly
and if so how does that happen because
we know
every one of us that there are some
cases where people are friends with each
other
and it totally blinds them right they
can't see what's going on with the other
person
or because their family connection or
you know they're in love with the other
person they can't see that the other
person is a user so we know that there's
some cases where there's epistemological
problems that arise but could there be
could it be that you actually need to
feel desire
to see certain things in the world or
you actually need to love
in a less interested way a more giving
way
in order to see things rightly those are
philosophical questions yeah
why do something else like strive for
women when other people kind of
stay away from it ah yeah why do some
people
strive for love what is it that they're
looking for in love
there are some people who love to be
loved right and
why do some other people say ah i got to
stay away
i don't want to get burned again or i
know love is is trouble
it's going to interfere with my career
yeah um
kind of given a mistaken understanding
of ourselves or the world or the
the object of love yeah how much control
do we have over our desires
oh that's a big one because a lot of
times what do we say
we don't have any control right that's a
big
question how how much do we shape our
desires
do we have any role at all or are we
like totally
ether at their mercy let's stop with
that one